what specifically grabs you about alumni
issues and if you dream big what do you
what do you see for the aya and five
years or 50 years hmm boy the aya has
come a long way in the last five years
and that's a really printed question
because we are actually looking to see
what we're what we're going to be like
five years from now what grabs me about
alumni issues I don't think it's any one
issue I think it's how you engage alumni
to serve Yale serve each other and serve
the world that's really what the a way
is focused on and that means that we try
to engage alumni in the way that they
are happiest connecting or they feel
passionate about connecting and I see
specific programming that we'd be
thinking about in the next five years
but I think what we want to do is first
of all inform the Alumni population that
that's really what we're all about now
and try to bring more of them into the
the fold to do just that but I see
really sort of anchoring our gains as
far as that that's a change from how the
a why used to be so anchoring our gains
around that bringing more people into
the fold and and then you know there's
some specific programming which is
probably not what you're asking me well
and so what do you sort of understand
it's like the really really big picture
you know 50 years from now you know what
does the a way it looked like what can
you tell us that's a really good
question I think 50 years from now I
think Yale students will understand what
the aya what their alumni life might
look like when they're freshmen as soon
as they walk in the door they'll see the
they'll see the connection was Yale is a
lifelong thing and that's really what
we're trying to do with the anyway I
think that's going to take a lot of time
but that's really the goal to see
yourself from the beginning as someone
who has this relationship with other
Yale ease and with the university that
helps inform how you act in the world
for a lifetime and then can you explain
why you think that's important well I
think Yale is a place that and I think
this may be partly self-selection yells
a place that tends to when they say
there
guilt actually states that it wants to
Train global leaders okay and we're not
just talking about people to leave
corporations or law firms and I think
he'll actually attracts a person who's
interested in being a leader in every
aspect of his or her life and and giving
back is a really big part of that it's
incredible to me when I talk to other
alums and we talk about what we've done
it the a way recently to do go beyond
your you know what class are you in or
what region do you live in people are so
attracted to that idea because they do
they it resonates with them it resonates
with yell ease the notion of giving back
and giving back in in lots of different
ways and I wasn't intentional about that
I wouldn't have been able to answer this
question in the same way when I started
when someone just asked me I did it
because I thought well it'll be fun to
hang out with the alleys but now now I
see that that's really common thread
that people respond to and act on